die nachrichten des tages
heute mit mitri sirin
deutschland hat wieder große corona
sorgen allerdings ist die situation
nicht vergleichbar mit vor einem jahr
und damit ihnen allen ganz herzlich
willkommen freut mich sehr dass sie
dabei sind genauso wie katja stresow für
den sport helmut lang und wir blicken
jetzt mal genauer auf unsere heutigen
themen
neue corona höchstwerte und die frage
nach der richtigen strategie im
bundestag wird heftig über die pläne der
ampel parteien gestritten
lang gewartet endlich gestartet der
deutsche matthias maurer ist auf dem weg
zur internationalen raumstation iss und
karneval in kona zeiten streng
kontrolliert starten die jecken in die
saison
über 50.000 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden wieder hilferufe von
intensivmedizinern dazu lauter werdende
forderungen nach impfpflicht nach
shutdown und weihnachtsmarkt verbot nach
zwei oder drei gehen die politik steht
unter großem handlungsdruck genauer die
ampel parteien die bald zusammen
regieren wollen ihre corona pläne wurden
heute kontrovers im bundestag diskutiert
vor dem schlagabtausch zeit pablo seal
al aridi corona fakten und die pläne der
ampel
50.000
196 neuinfektionen so viel wie noch nie
und noch ein rekord die sieben tage
inzidenz steigt weiter auf 249 1
bemerkbar macht sich die situation auch
auf den intensivstationen nach einem
anstieg im frühjahr hatte sich die zahl
der kogit patienten dort zunächst
verringert doch nun füllen sich die
stationen wieder
die epidemische notlage nationaler
tragweite läuft in zwei wochen aussetzen
wollen sie die ampel parteien durch
einen bundesweiten maßnahmenkatalog
der sieht unter anderem die möglichkeit
vor am arbeitsplatz die 3g regel
einzuführen das heißt die beschäftigten
brauchen einen impf oder genesenen
nachweis oder täglich ein neues
negatives testergebnis
bislang können die länder 18 mögliche
maßnahmen gegen die pandemie anwenden
künftig nur noch sechs
wegfallen sollen vor allem besonders
harte maßnahmen wie ausgangssperren
schulschließungen und kontakt
beschränkungen
so weit wichtiger ausschnitte der ampel
pläne die heute bei der ersten
inhaltlichen sitzung im neu
aufgestellten bundestag natürlich auf
ein geteiltes echo stießen über die
debatte und den mit spannung erwarteten
auftritt des vielleicht nächsten
bundeskanzlers ines trams
noch hat sie nicht an ihn übergeben noch
ist die ampel koalition nicht im amt
doch die zeit drängt die vierte welle
zieht durchs land nun legen die
koalitionäre in spe eine neufassung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes vor es gelte so
olaf scholz deutschland winterfest zu
machen das virus ist noch unter uns und
bedroht die gesundheit der bürgerinnen
und bürger
und deshalb ist es ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir alle maßnahmen ergreifen um
sicher zu sein dass wir die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen bürger unseres landes
schützen können auch wenn die lage
anders ist weil so viele geimpft sind
ist sie noch nicht gut die union
probiert sich als oppositionsführer dass
die sogenannte epidemische notlage
nationaler tragweite ende november
auslaufen soll kritisiert sie als
realitätsverweigerung auch wenn es ihr
gesundheitsminister war der das angeregt
hatte es ist kommunikativ auch das
völlig falsche signal dadurch dass sie
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite aufheben sagen sie doch den
leuten es ist nicht mehr so schlimm wir
mussten diesen entwurf hier vorlegen
weil eben nichts vorbereitet worden ist
von ihnen und der vorgänger regierung
und vom bundesgesundheitsminister der in
diesem sommer gesagt hat 'jetzt können
vor allem in den augen der fdp ist diese
rechtliche grundlage nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig damit war es der
bundesregierung beispielsweise möglich
kontakt beschränkungen zu verhängen ich
finde wir müssen auch in der krise unser
grundgesetz respektieren damit wir das
bleiben was wir sind und was wir sein
wollen nämlich ein freiheitlicher
rechtsstaat meine damen und die afd
deren ungeimpfte abgeordnete wegen der
geltenden 3g regel im bundestag auf der
tribüne sitzen müssen kritisiert
sämtliche maßnahmen als unzulässigen
druck auf ungeimpfte wie als auf die
fraktion wir haben ein anderes ein
freiheitliches menschenbild im vergleich
zu ihnen allen für uns ist die impfung
eine persönliche entscheidung eines
jeden bürgers und diese entscheidung
muss freiwillig und ohne direkten oder
indirekten zwang erfolgen die linke
kritisiert die alte und die womöglich
neue regierung gleichermaßen auch diese
vierte welle würde über den
verantwortlichen zusammenschlagen das
war halt so ein bisschen absurdes
theater für mich herr scholz ich weiß
nicht wann sie in den letzten jahren
nicht in der regierungsverantwortung
denn die ganzen dinge nicht gemacht wie
sie vorgeschlagen haben der erste
gesetzentwurf der ampel die abstimmung
darüber ist für nächste woche geplant
dazu wird es ein bund länder treffen
geben dass auch die noch kanzlerin
gefordert hatte
fragen wir nach bei theo koll in berlin
der sich die debatte genau angeschaut
hat theo angesichts der sich
verschärfenden corona situation wie
erfolg versprechen können die ampel
pläne sein und zumindest juristisch
sollen die ampel pläne
erfolgversprechender weil gerichts
fester sein und der bundestag holt sich
die demokratische kontrolle zurück das
ist aber dann auch das einzig positive
über das man sich hier einig ist
kritisiert wird vor allem dass das
signal die epidemische notlage auslaufen
zu lassen zum denkbar schlechtesten
moment kommt beim rekordwert von über
50.000 neuinfektionen pro tag sende das
in der öffentlichen wahrnehmung das
falsche signal so hat es heute selbst
ein
spd-ministerpräsident kritisiert und aus
dem berühmten instrumentenkasten gegen
die pandemie werden mit dem
gesetzentwurf die schärfsten werkzeuge
rausgenommen also ausgangssperren
schulschließungen kontakt sind dann ja
nicht mehr möglich und ob die
verbleibenden maßnahmen wirklich
ausreichen werden der exponentielle
entwicklung herr zu werden das wird von
nicht wenigen experten bezweifelt vielen
dank nach berlin theo koll ja wie
umgehen mit grassierenden infektionen
zahlen und zunehmender intensivbetten
belegung der deutsche ethikrat fordert
die bundesregierung auf eine impfpflicht
für bestimmte berufsgruppen zu prüfen
zum beispiel für alle arbeitenden in
pflegeheim aber weil auch geimpfte das
virus weitergeben können müssen auch sie
sich in vielen heimen konsequent auf das
virus testen lassen malin ihlau
berichtet aus niedersachsen das heim in
hannover ihre schutzburg gegen korona
allein auf ihrem zimmer fühlt sich elke
christiansen sicherer vor zwei jahren
kam sie hierhin hat erlebt wie das virus
ins haus kam eine verschärfung der test
pflicht für pflegekräfte heimbewohner
und besucher würde sie richtig finden
meinen sohn der in hannover lebt der hat
mich überwiegend besucht einmal die
woche und der musste immer sich testen
lassen und der würde das jetzt also auch
mitmachen letzte woche gab es hier einen
impf durchbruch mittlerweile sind 98
prozent der heimbewohner und
pflegekräfte zum dritten mal geimpft
doch das alles reicht nicht aus sagen
patientenschützer die anstrengungen für
die pflegebedürftigen seien derzeit viel
zu gering um
getestet das personal ungetestete
besucherinnen und besucher dürfen nicht
in ein pflegeheim
wir brauchen eine tägliche test pflicht
für alle auch für die geimpften und
gelesenen gerade in zeiten des
personalmangels eine aufwändige
forderung also schon ein riesiger
aufwand wir müssen jeden test
durchgeführt wird auch dokumentieren es
muss eine kollegin die eingearbeitet
wurde in die tests zu bestimmten zeiten
in bestimmte zimmer hinterlegt werden
dass die die angehörigen die bewohner
auch noch mal testen und top
derzeit werden hier im seniorenstift die
pflegekräfte dreimal die woche getestet
ungeimpfte pflegekräfte jeden tag
eine weitere säule im kampf gegen korona
sind medikamente jetzt hat die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde grünes
licht für zwei präparate gegeben die zu
einem frühen zeitpunkt der infektion
eingesetzt werden können es handelt sich
dabei um antikörpertherapien des
schweizer pharmaunternehmens roche und
des herstellers zentren aus südkorea und
zur krone krise hier bei uns ein zdf
spezial direkt im anschluss an diese
heute sendung ja in dieser corona
situation da gerät die suche nach der
neuen führung in der cdu fast ein wenig
aus dem blick jetzt aber gibt es einen
ersten offiziellen bewerber der
bisherige kanzleramtsminister helge
braun will seinen hut in den ring werfen
es hat seinen hessischen landesverband
bestätigt als weitere kandidaten werden
norbert röttgen und friedrich merz
genannt die haben allerdings noch nicht
ihre bewerbung erklärt
das ist in schwierigen zeiten eine gute
nachricht nicht nur für die künftige
regierung die steuereinnahmen werden
wohl deutlich höher ausfallen als
gedacht noch-finanzminister olaf scholz
stellte heute die prognose des
arbeitskreises steuerschätzung vor
179 milliarden euro zusätzlich kommen
demnach bis 2025 in die kassen von bund
ländern und kommunen
der grund für den optimismus im nächsten
jahr soll die wirtschaft kräftig
anziehen
schauen wir jetzt auf die dramatische
lage an der eu-außengrenze zwischen
polen und belarus tausende migranten
harren dort seit tagen benutzt vom
belarussischen machthaber lukaschenko
aus dass der vorwurf um ein ende der
sanktionen gegen sein land zu erpressen
sie schlafen im freien bei temperaturen
um den gefrierpunkt
campieren am zaun an der grenze zu polen
und sie kommen nicht vor und nicht
zurück peter theißen
es sollen um die 4000 menschen sein die
derzeit frierend und sehnsüchtig direkt
über den grenzzaun blicken immer wieder
schaffen es einige nach polen wie josef
atilla aus syrien der erzählt es sein
belarussische sicherheitskräfte gewesen
die ihn so übel zugerichtet hätten
sie haben uns aufgegriffen dann hat eine
angefangen mir ins gesicht zu treten
hier ist was gebrochen die nase auch
danach so erzählt er hätten die bälle
russischen sicherheitskräfte ihn und
andere flüchtlinge gezielt an die grenze
zu polen transportiert
sie haben uns in einem wagen in die
sperrzone zwischen polen und belarus
gebracht und dann gesagt wir sollten
einfach nach polen rüber laufen
in berlin derweil großer applaus für die
frau die belarus ein anderes gesicht
geben wollte svetlana d janowski
oppositionsführerin im exil hört wie der
deutsche außenminister den ton gegenüber
dem diktator in minsk verschärft die
europäische union wird ihre sanktionen
gegen lukaschenko regime ausweiten und
verschärft und das werden wir am montag
im außenrat in brüssel beschließen
diejenigen personen und unternehmen die
sich an der gezielten schleusung
beteiligen werden wir weiter
sanktionieren und zwar überall auf der
welt der belarussische präsident
lukaschenko wiederum reagiert mit
drohgebärden wir sorgen in europa für
wärme und sie drohen uns was wenn wir
die gas lieferungen stoppen er
verschweigt dass nur ein kleiner teil
des gases für europa durch belarus
fließt tausende flüchtlinge harren aus
am grenzzaun oder in den belarussischen
wäldern 15.000 polnische soldaten
versuchen sie abzuwehren es wird immer
kälter zwischen polen und belarus
was die menschen auf ihrem weg durch
belarus erleben darüber berichtet auch
zdf heute live um 19 uhr 45 in der zdf-
heute- app und auf unseren social media
kanälen
frederik willem de klerk war der letzte
präsident des rassistischen
apartheid-systems in südafrika und
leitete dessen ende ein jetzt ist er im
alter von 85 jahren gestorben
anfang der 90er jahre hat er sich de
klerk für das ende der rassentrennung
eingesetzt und für die freilassung
seines späteren nachfolgers nelson
mandela 1993 erhielten beide den
friedensnobelpreis die nelson mandela
stiftung würdigte de klerk sein
vermächtnis sei groß aber auch
unausgewogen weil er sich geweigert
hatte die apartheid als verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit zu bezeichnen
jetzt können wir zu einer ganz
besonderen reise die mehrfach verschoben
werden musste aber heute morgen um 3 uhr
drei dann schließlich geklappt hat an
bord einer space extrem kapsel hob der
deutsche matthias maurer ab ins all mit
drei weiteren astronauten ist er jetzt
auf dem weg zur internationalen
raumstation iss
dem größten menschengemachten objekt im
weltraum spannweite 109 meter die
nächsten sechs monate wird maurer vor
allem im columbus modul der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa arbeiten über die
mission cosmic ist berichtet jetzt
susanne freitag
[Applaus]
matthias maurer mit crew 3 ist auf dem
weg in die schwerelosigkeit
bilderbuchstart sagen die
kontrollzentren alles läuft nach plan
wenn das so bleibt dann locken sie
morgen früh um 1 uhr an der iss an beim
deutschen institut für luft und
raumfahrt wissen sie genau was den
astronauten dann erwartet
ich glaube der erste stock wird sein
wenn die lupe geöffnet wird weil
natürlich auf der raum saison die luft
wird zwar gereinigt von co2 und so
weiter aber es ist halt doch
abgestandene luft ist sehr warm oben er
wird erst mal vielleicht mal die nase
rümpfen dann gewöhnt man sich dran sie
können nicht eben nicht einfach lüften
und da geht die arbeit los
als erster deutscher fliegt matthias
maurer mit einer rakete der privaten
firma spacex von ihnen masse in den
orbit um dort über 100 experimente zu
machen in seinem heimatdorf obertal
maurer mann ihr sogar das gepäck haben
sie thematisch angepasst ist schließlich
ihr astro matthias
ich finds mega habe den staat auch
mitverfolgt bin extra früh aufgestanden
war gänsehaut moment in der kapsel sind
sie inzwischen schwereres ein
unglaubliches erlebnis so funken sie
nach unten auf die erde ihr maskottchen
ist ev eine schildkröte stimmung gut
wir haben schon mal aus dem fenster
geguckt und die allerersten fotos
gemacht und zu üben fotos von uns will
in schweden sowie carrier grade
und schon bald werden sie ihr ziel
erreichen die iss das höchste
forschungslabor der welt
ja und wenn sie jetzt selbst zur iss
hoch wollen probieren sie's ich kann das
wirklich empfehlen mit der zdf heute app
können sie das fliegen der mega labor im
all erleben in dem 16 nationen gemeinsam
forschen einfach das modell drehen und
anklicken und dann sehen sie wer dabei
ist
heute war doch war es heute ist der
elfte elfte was ganze regionen am rhein
normalerweise in sofortige feier laune
versetzt beginn der fünften jahreszeit
dieser elfter elfter ist aber sie können
sich das vorstellen wegen der
galoppierenden corona zahlen völlig
anders in den karnevalshochburgen gilt
zweig in abgesperrten feierzonen und
trotzdem fragen sich viele ob das gut
gehen kann bobby cherry
die karnevalssaison in köln startet in
diesem jahr mit einer zweig kontrolle
nur geimpfte und genesene dürfen auf den
zentralen plätzen mit feiern am heumarkt
sind ganze 11 tausend jecken erlaubt
ich denke da sollte man eigentlich keine
angst haben was uns hier was passiert es
genug platte mit ihr zu eng wird gehe
ich ein paar schritte nach hinten party
im präsenz es sind ungewohnte bilder
mitten in der pandemie das kölner
dreigestirn fehlte heute auf der bühne
denn der prinz hat corona
der schunkel und gesang nur für geimpfte
und genesene auch auf dem mainzer
schillerplatz
7.500 teilnehmer ein mindestabstand
keine maske
feiern im freien offiziell ist das in
rheinland pfalz sogar ohne personen
beschränkung 2g 3g und maske erlaubt wie
lange das fragen sich auch die narren
wie das dann auf der straße bei der
straßenfastnacht oder gar bei den zügen
aussieht das steht in den sternen das
wissen wir alles noch nicht da müssen
wir einfach die entwicklung im januar
und im februar abwarten obwohl heute
wieder gefeiert werden durfte bleiben
offene fragen zum start in die fünfte
jahreszeit
wir bieten jetzt ab zum sport und katja
stresow und die beginnt mit einem mann
der fußball deutschland einen der
schönsten momente beschert paar tage ist
es her 2014 war das heute abend wird der
ehemalige und weltmeister bundestrainer
joachim löw in wolfsburg vor dem
wm-qualifikationsspiel
offiziell verabschiedet deutschland
spielt gegen den krassen außenseiter
liechtenstein ohne einige stammspieler
und vor ausverkaufter kulisse
für die angereisten fans gilt sie kommen
nur in die arena wenn sie geimpft oder
genesen sind für das länderspiel in
wolfsburg gilt die zweijährige 26.000
sind dabei wenn jogi löw feierlich
verabschiedet wird sein langjähriger
assistent und noch ungeschlagener
nachfolger hansi flick würdigte den
weltmeister coach bereits vor der ehrung
weil er als mensch außergewöhnlich ist
und den druck den er hatte hat er nie
irgendwie weitergegeben das ist eine
ganz große stärke auch von ihm gewesen
135 tage nach seinem letzten länderspiel
heute das schlusskapitel
man hat immer wieder berührungspunkte
gehabt und auch sich toll ausgetauscht
und ein war auch viel spaß und einfach
eine gute zeit miteinander gehabt der
löw abschied gleichzeitig das erste
zweig länderspiel für fans die schon vor
dem stadion ihre nachweise vorzeigen
müssen
bereits gestern abend war
internationaler frauenfußball angesagt
das spitzenspiel in der champions league
allerdings ohne ein erfolgserlebnis für
die spielerinnen von fc bayern münchen
sie verloren gegen den rekordsieger
olympique lyon mit 1 zu 2
jubel bei den spielerinnen von olympique
lyon und ein nachdenklicher bayern
trainer jens scheuer trotz guten spiels
sein team gestern ohne zählbares die
münchnerinnen gehen den führungen druck
auf buchanan und eigentor lyon in der
fünfundzwanzigste 100 der halbzeitstand
nach dem wechsel durcheinander im
gästestrafraum tiemann mit dem eins zu
eins in der 55 die bayern frauen glauben
an den punkt aber nur bis zur 58 minute
die spinnt er als kumagai und trifft per
kopf zum sieg für die französinnen in
summe es ist ärgerlich wie die tore
müssen einfach gefangen haben und dann
wird hier natürlich schwer gegen leo
schwär und erfolglos in einer woche
sehen sie sich in münchen wieder
und drehten das ergebnis dann einfach
vielen dank katja wir beide fanden heute
teilweise ganz schön nebelig bleibt auch
weiterhin so gibt noch ein bisschen
sonne dazu allerdings mit großen
temperaturunterschieden mehr dazu gleich
von katja uefa ich empfehle noch
christian sievers mit dem heute-journal
wie immer um viertel vor zehn das
gesamte 19 uhr heute team bedankt sich
fürs zuschauen freut sich auch morgen
wieder auf sie schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend heute gab es große
unterschiede beim wetter und auch bei
den temperaturen mit strahlendem
sonnenschein kletterten die temperaturen
in mittenwald am alpenrand ist auf 18
grad wenn es aber trüb blieb wie zb
einigen flusstälern hier an der donau
und auch am rhein dann blieb es sehr
kalt andernach meldete uns eine
höchsttemperatur von nur zwei grad heute
nacht sinken die temperaturen auf +3 bis
-2 grad am boden wird also wieder
frostig und es kann auch alles glatt
sein im norden bleibt es deutlich milder
mit 8 bis 5 grad das liegt an den
dichteren wolken im norden die
allerdings nur noch selten etwas regen
mitbringen in der mitte und im süden ist
entweder klar oder es bildet sich wieder
nebel und erhält sich auch morgen in
einigen flusstälern süddeutschlands c
auf der nordseite der mittelgebirge und
am alpenrand sehen sie dagegen sehr gut
die sonne und auch in norddeutschland
wird sie häufiger zum zuge kommen nur
hier so zwischen der uckermark und
nordfriesland bleibt es wohl bedeckt so
liegen morgen die höchsttemperaturen im
norden bei 7 bis 11 grad im dauer grau
sind es dagegen nur so drei bis sieben
am alpenrand 14 grad am samstag kontern
ein kleines tief heran das verlässt uns
am sonntag südwärts und die neue woche
startet wieder mit novemberwetter guten
abend